hello and welcome to this video playing
mr. queen ever
queen ever okay so we got the French
exchange with Bishop g4 and
and I had this on the board a lot then
the Bishop g4 line somehow rarely seen
in my games up to this point okay let's
see what she is going to play this line
is better for widest absolutely no
argument damn the main question is what
black is playing here yeah okay this is
this is not good but it's it's a bit
tricky you can play actually a three but
the simplest thing is to just do this
and send it back a three is good for
white but really complicated and you can
easily yeah tangle yourself up knight
Knight f6 is usually a mistake because
of 95
if it takes twice f4 f5 and then winning
the bishop and I'm threatening 90 xe6 so
hmm
yeah why is that possible if I take C
six that should be terrible Queen a six
[Music]
yeah okay
Queen a six
should be the way to start and now if a
plane Knight takes d5 by the way Knight
takes d5 pawn takes Bishop b5 is a
complete complete route it's just made
basically it's major okay and 95 what's
happening then 26 26 could probably the
only answer
it's a really wonder there should be a
way to win the position outright
I totally want to take night a for is a
move that is kind of intriguing I don't
know come on after playing with 90 to 95
is killing
okay so
[Music]
now k94 was not the best this is much
this much I know now I mean black black
should just be busted after allowing all
this but he isn't so I did something
wrong
tweenage for maybe such simple play
maybe it is just okay for now
my queen looks a little bit offside
queen a7 threatening at least Knight b6
now which is duly ignored as I'm used to
people never really react to any threat
somehow like nothing is happening okay
yeah he could be it was possible
we should be forced my gym
and now he's attacking c2 and my rook
fantastic what the heck what did what a
game what a game I don't get it really
he lost Knight X is six and somehow I'm
not punishing it it's absolutely
atrocious absolutely terrible how can
you lose this even
my Scot Queen takes d4 unfortunately
mmm this is actually not so easy to play
my queen is coming to dark g1g 6 these
kind of things
Queen age 8 threatening Wow yeah well I
do not understand the game it seems like
how can black not be totally lost yeah
after night before I mean the position
here must be already pretty awful but
how can you not be lost I mean probably
because I did something stupid but so
take take and I have a hard time to
believe that green a6 is supposed to be
not best I mean if you okay if you have
to take on you for which just may be
possible then you should do it now
and not play the check first problem
right okay I still cannot believe that
is bad my knight a voice even not
heavily criticized but at the engine at
first now maybe it's easier to just take
on your form I mean it's quite clear
that in something like that white is
better for forever and it's the better
structure is 7 then the pods are all
weak and the King is more and save but
still it feels a bit odd that there is
no direct punishment Queen f6 I was a
good defense rookie to probably have to
do it age five and maybe Bishop g2 was
wrong even
likes forced and now this ship takes you
form it's not the best it seems but and
here I probably have to do something
else here Queen a7 yeah and that was
that was unbelievable to me like a fish
let's move it I probably wanna know when
I did not see as I was thinking he just
has this MOOC was and I did not see
night a8 in this position night a8 we
have let's just win how does he cover
that that doesn't work yeah I mean now I
was really unnerved night be 698 still
wins I'm sure before I simply overlooked
that double attack and I'm still winning
well when I p6 crazy here in Bishop
before as possible
you have this fortunately the idea of
cause I'm just totally lost it
yeah can still try try to pose some
problems here with the weak in position
okay guys thanks a lot for watching